hey guys i'm ryan right so we're
youtubers and we thought we should share
our top 5 favorite youtubers let's get
into this
my list is mainly comprised of people
who I will binge watch basically yeah
there's a lot of great youtubers out
there but these are the ones where I
like I will just keep going through the
other videos so number 5 for me is jenna
Marbles first came across her Murray my
neighbor showed me who she was and she's
hilarious kiss geyser know she does a
lot of sketches and stuff and she is
really good-looking too like it's hard
to find someone who's really
good-looking and really funny especially
on the Internet steers Sally who's your
number 5 so my number 5 is going to be
charlie is so cool like because he's
just like who he is a British youtuber I
just love him cuz he's so cute and like
he did like one video about science and
and I was completely into it because
he's just so good-looking and if he did
more videos like that I learned a lot
more anyway no he's just a really smart
guy and I like it because he's just
different like he says a lot of things
that I can relate to as a person on
YouTube so I just I want like I would
have eaten it okay you can sit on his
face one day my number four is
cinemasins they go through movies and
they basically count the sins like every
little mistake that someone makes in a
movie they will point it out and so many
times I'm like sometimes it's just like
okay that's funny and silly but other
times I'm like I can't believe I didn't
notice that like that is so true that is
a big mistake
Prometheus does suck so yeah my number
four is gonna be GG gorgeous because
like GG is just garde ass probably you
don't know it's actually a transgendered
woman and I like this youtuber because I
don't know I just watched her
his her meet her I'll say that I watched
her videos and she just makes me laugh
because you still look over the top and
like [ __ ] but in a fun way like I
won't really want to hang out with her
or some day I don't know I just like her
stories they made me laugh and I'm not a
transgendered woman so I just find it
really interesting there are people -
Sally yeah they're people - my number
three is epic rap battles they'll take
characters from TV shows from history
like fictional movies and whatever to
have them in the characters do rap
battles and it's not like they're just
saying rap battle stuff like it is very
detailed and you have to be in the know
of these characters it's actually
incredibly clever super catchy super
entertaining so my number three is going
to be smush
because I've been a fan of them since I
was like a freshman in high school and
they were my crushes a long time ago and
I like I feel like I've grown with them
on YouTube and they were my inspiration
for a couple of my stupid short sketches
I like their older stuff more but
they're still really funny guys so maybe
one day you can have sex with all of
them at the same time they call that a
gaming my number two is screen junkies
they do a lot of movie news and such but
their main thing is honest trailers if
you guys haven't seen honest trailers
they basically give you the truth of
movies as well similar to cinema sins
but do trailer format so check them out
right the [ __ ] away do it my number two
gotta be Djibouti dubs because I love
dubbing videos I will watch them to the
end of time and these guys they do like
the infomercials they dub the
infomercials and stuff and like other
random things they dub old cartoons like
the old he-man cartoons and spider-man
it's so funny like I was laughing at
3:00 in the morning so I was crying and
I woke people up that's how funny they
are so I got it
you just want to have sex with a lot of
people I don't even know what they look
like and why would I want to have sex
see this is why I get haters on my
channel calling me a [ __ ] no because
this guy saying that I want to have sex
with everyone it's not true though horny
addict I'm not oh no you wouldn't have
talked the jenna Marbles
what doesn't well so then why can't you
call him this letter Oh what my
girlfriend wouldn't want to have sex
with jenna Marbles probably which I
would be okay with baby no it actually
really heard if you did that I'm very
emotional
my number one is Jeremy John's I got
nervous to put him on the list because
people see my movie reviews and they're
like your coffee and Jeremy Jones I
don't actually agree with that I don't
say the same stuff he says I usually
don't watch his review prior to me doing
mine because I don't want to get anyone
else's opinions in my head but Jeremy
Jones first youtuber I ever watched i
binge watches videos I'm always anytime
he has a video out if I'm gonna review
the movie I wait til I watch the movie
but if not I immediately go to his
channel I love watching his topic videos
I love watching his top ten and all that
he's just an awesome youtuber and he has
like the perfect videos for movie
reviews he's hands-down the best movie
critic I know on YouTube next to me I'm
pretty [ __ ] amazing I am Number One I
almost put the real rejects as my top
really my number one that's crazy
because I I I put some in your salary
and I raised it yeah I'm trying to be
humble yeah my number one is Julian
Smith i think is actually username on
youtubes julian smith 87 majors goes by
julian smith anyway go to his channel
because a lot of people don't know about
him he has like over a million
subscribers because he's amazing but he
actually is a cinematographer so all of
his videos you said a lot of people
don't know about him he has a million
subscribers no but in comparison to all
the big youtubers i have like 13 million
that is an hour little number for a
youtuber which is really bad i don't
know how our channels look so good
Julian slipped Oh Julian he has a
character called Jeffrey Dallas and I
can't even like it's Jeffrey Dahmer no
Jeffrey Dahmer and he's like kind of
mentally like I have a lot of inside
jokes with my friends with his videos
which is why I hold him so close to my
heart so yes I really want to work and
we both have a gap in our teeth
I just like wanted that gap actually
developed once Sally hit puberty because
then she started experimenting I'm
trying to make a [ __ ] joke here don't
though anyway guys that's our top 5
favorite youtuber list what are your top
5 favorite youtubers comment below and
let me know
and as always are you going now I'm not
gonna do all that and you can subscribe
to the real rejects where there's stuff
and you could check out salamander
Sally's channel she has boobs what do
you what do you say to promote
yourselves
um yeah I'm you know a girl I have boobs
congratulations red hair which is fine
that's always fun
the carpet does not match the drapes
okay okay so she made that clear
and yeah you guys have a good night